fabrice grosse pile et journalise
bonsoir fabrice grosfilley merci d'être
avec nous en direct sur rt france la
belgique qui compte actuellement 1486
cas dépistés au comique 19 14 mort
beaucoup moins que chez nous et pourtant
les mêmes mesures
oui comme chez vous il faudra rappeler
qu' à 12 millions d'habitants belgique a
donc il faut faire une règle de trois
ils ont d'autres qu'on a aussi quelques
jours peut-être une semaine de retard la
progression de la pandémie
puisqu'on a bien compris cette endémie
elle était partie l'italie etc a
vraiment progressivement vers le nord de
l'europe donc effectivement 243 cas
supplémentaires aujourd'hui et 14 morts
on était à dix morts ici hier donc on a
le sentiment que la progression reste
relativement contenue et l'espoir des
autorités belges
bah c'est de se dire qu'on a peut-être
pris les mesures de confinement attend
on les a pris juste dans la foulée de la
france est en tout cas par rapport au
développement ce qui s'est passé en
italie plus plutôt que ce qu'elle avait
fait et les autorités italiennes
n'avaient pas dire que ces mesures
auront été facile à prendre
il ya eu beaucoup de discussions on a
d'ailleurs observé qu' entre les
néerlandophones au nord du pays et les
francophones au sud du pays
on a lu un petit peu de mal à accorder
les violons les francophones qui regarde
évidemment ce qui se passe beaucoup en
france demandé des mesures fortes
rapidement les néerlandophones ont eu
quelques jours de réflexion
supplémentaire avant de se rallier à la
même idée m'est donc effectivement c'est
un confinement où on peut encore aller
travailler pour ceux qui ne peuvent pas
être télétravail et dont la présence est
indispensable confinement on peut
également effectivement aller faire ses
courses se rendre à la pharmacie se
rendre à la vente si c'est nécessaire et
sortir mais sous des conditions
relativement strictes à dire qu'on va
sortir uniquement accompagnés des
personnes de la même famille qui
vivaient sous le même toit et on doit
garder ce qu'on appelle ici une
distanciation social c'est bien une
distance d'au moins un mètre cinquante
avec les personnes que l'on croisé
évidemment depuis les plus d'une semaine
déjà et les interdits
de se faire la bise de se serrer la main
et d'autres mesures de ce type là ça
veut dire concrètement fabrice
grosfilley que les exemples italien et
même français ont quand même inquiété
clairement les belges parce que ok pour
la règle de 3 enfin les mesures ont été
prises
vous l'avez d'ailleurs très bien
souligné beaucoup plus tôt qu'en france
alors un petit peu plus tôt qu'en france
si on observe le décalage maintenant la
france avait un impact parce que par
exemple quand il l'a fallu interdire les
écoles les écoles sont pas fermés ici
c'est à dire que ce sont les cours qui
sont suspendus on a demandé aux parents
de garder les enfants chez eux mais les
écoles restent ouvertes pour pouvoir
accueillir les enfants pour lesquels il
n'y a pas de solution gab d'abord pour
tous les parents qui travaillent dans le
domaine de la santé ou le domaine de la
sécurité et aussi pour toutes les
familles qui n'avaient pas d'autre
solution que de laisser les parents
auprès de leurs grands-parents ce qu'on
essaye à tout prix d'éviter c'est
justement ce mélange intergénérationnel
où on met des jeunes autres c'est qu'ils
sont porteurs de peut-être de la maladie
mais qu'ils n'ont pas de symptômes qui
ne vont pas la développer sous une forme
sévère et puis des des plus âgés qui eux
ont un risque beaucoup plus important en
terme en termes de santé donc on essaye
à tout prix d'empêcher cette mixité
générationnelle
donc on a laissé les écoles ouvertes il
ya deux à trois pour cent des élèves qui
continuent d'aller dans les écoles où on
assure un système de cartes de risques
qu'on ne donne pas qu il y en a on
accueille les enfants pour lesquels n'y
a pas d'autre solution que cette mesure
là par exemple elle était plutôt voulu
par les hommes politiques francophones
et les néerlandophones était par contre
réticents et il faut savoir que le
conseil national de sécurité qui est
donc l'organe qui décident de ce type de
mesure en belgique était en réunion au
moment où est mené le maquereau a fait
son discours où il annoncé cette mesure
pour la france et c'est ce discours d'
emmanuel macron qui est un petit peu
débloquer la situation et qui a fait
basculer la décision d'envoyer que la
france a effectivement alors si par
rapport à la pandémie un petit peu de
retard par rapport aux mesures prises en
belgique mais elle joue aussi un rôle un
petit peu prescripteurs parce qu'on
regarde
les forces qui se passe en france on
essaye d'en tirer les leçons et on
essaye effectivement d'aller peut-être
un petit peu plus vite que les français
en tout cas de se calquer sur la mesure
mais d'avoir peut-être un petit peu un
coup d'avancé par rapport à ce qui s'est
passé chez vous justement l'instabilité
gouvernementale en belgique
c'est très longtemps sans son
gouvernement est ce que ça vous semble
être un frein à la bonne gestion de
cette crise ou pas forcément alors
paradoxalement non ça fait un an
maintenant plus d'un an même que nous
sommes sans gouvernement puisque le
gouvernement a fait chuter sur les
questions de politique internationale on
était resté sans gouvernement de plein
exercice avec un gouvernement en
affaires courantes jusqu'aux élections
et puis depuis les élections on essaye
des formes de gouvernement il on n'y
arrive pas parce que le problème de
linguistique est une vraie difficulté
aujourd'hui en belgique mais le
gouvernement d'affaires courantes
il a la possibilité d'agir malgré tout
sur les affaires urgentes et évidemment
la crise à l'italie n'a fait rire
hollande est donc la ministre de la
santé avait quand même la latitude de
pouvoir agir ce qui s'est passé ces
dernières semaines c'est que les partis
politiques ont bien compris que face à
la crise on ne pourrait pas continuer à
être dans cette espèce de crise
politique continue l on a tenté de
former un gouvernement
final on n'y est pas parvenu mais en
revanche les partis de l'opposition une
grande partie des partis d'opposition en
tout cas parti socialiste francophone a
indiqué qu'il acceptait maintenant de
soutenir le gouvernement de l'extérieur
et donc ce déblocage la a permis
d'installer un nouveau gouvernement qui
est au départ un gouvernement basé sur
trois partis qui sont très minoritaires
il n'en présente que 38 sièges sur les
150 de l'assemblée nationale mais ils
ont deux renforts des de la famille
socialiste de la famille écologiste d'un
parti social chrétien francophone qui ne
siège pas au gouvernement mais qui ont
accepté de l'appuyer l'extérieur de ce
qui fait que demain on aura donc un vote
de confiance pour installer l'ancien
gouvernement qui va devenir un nouveau
gouvernement de plein exercice qui en
plus on pourra être doté de ce qu'on
appelle ici les pouvoirs spéciaux
c'est à dire la capacité à pouvoir
prendre des mesures à pouvoir légiférer
sans passer
par la case parlementaire c'est bon on
validera législation décidé par ce
gouvernement aux partitions arrêt court
un cirque les ministres peuvent
légiférer et les parlementaires à
pouvons ou des approuveront plus tard on
a versé type processus c'est un une
procédure vraiment de temps de crise
elle a été utilisée dans les années 80
2000 lorsqu'il a fallu prendre des
mesures fortes pour rétablir l'économie
améliorer la tête donc les syndicats
belges sont un petit peu méfiant région
de mesures mais on a estimé qu'
aujourd'hui c'était vraiment
indispensable viens de lire un consensus
national autour de cette question avec
une exception c'est l'extrême droite
l'extrême droite flamand notamment et le
parti nationaliste flamand de bart de
wever qui demain ne devrait pas voter la
confiance et qui par contre pourrait
voter malgré tout les pouvoirs spéciaux
merci beaucoup fabrice grosfilley
d'avoir été avec nous en direct sur rt
france depuis la belgique